jean marie villemin a supplié
aujourd'hui muriel bolle de dire la
vérité sur la mort de son fils grégory
muriel bolle a dit sa vérité bernard
haller roche n'a pas tué grégory pas
payant chaque matin et ce depuis six
semaines jean marie villemin a tant que
muriel dise la vérité sur la mort de son
enfant
aussi aujourd'hui c'est lui qui passe
rend si l'on cherche ans à son tour à
déstabiliser le témoin tu as deux
enfants dont l'un à 4 ans l'âge qu'avait
grégory aujourd'hui grégory devoir 13
ans il faut que plus tard tu puisse
regarder tes enfants en passe
si tu peux vivre avec un secret aussi
monstrueux je te plains muriel ne se
démonte pas rendre je n'ai pas de secret
c'est quand même un toit qui est censée
warner et bernard il est innocent pour
la quatrième fois de belgique du procès
venture ober fait aulas à la cour
d'assises
il est évident que muriel n'a pas été
maltraités physiquement et moralement
elle a subi une pression psychologique
délicat le juge lambert ajoute elle
avait 15 ans et elle n'est pas non plus
une intellectuelle
cette pression muriel bolle la subit de
nouveau depuis quatre jours sans que
personne ne réussisse à trouver la
faille
villemain muriel bolle s'est enferré
dans un mensonge et la partie civile n'a
qu'un seul appui à l'issue de cette
sixième semaine de procès jean michel
lambert est une fois de plus le petit le
cours semble être un homme bien seul